hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to explain the solution to the
15 puzzle from last week but before i
get into that i want to explain three
clues
if you compare the original version of
the puzzle to the version we used the
version we used had round discs instead
of square blocks
the second clue is if you looked at the
transition between the puzzle
and its solution
the transition was a rotation transition
the third clue
is that i cut out
the 4x4 grid
which seemingly served no purpose at all
the reason was if you compared the
original configuration to the solved
puzzle
and you looked very closely you could
see
that the grid was actually rotated in
the solved puzzle from where it was
originally
all right let's get to the solution
we'll start by sliding
the disks around the perimeter of the
grid
the reason is that we want to get the
numbers 1 2 3 and 4
to be vertically on the right hand side
so keep sliding the numbers around
until you get two to be in the upper
right hand corner
at this point move the second column
slide that entire second column up
and this is because we want to exchange
the 14 in a different position
now we keep sliding the discs around the
perimeter
until we get one two three and four on
the right hand side
after we do this for a little while we
now very importantly need to move the 14
in between the 13 and 15 the 11 in
between the 10 and 12
and with the few obvious moves
we'll be able to get all of the numbers
in order
in columns on the right hand side
now comes the trick we rotate the entire
board 90 degrees counterclockwise
and then we rotate each of the discs 90
degrees clockwise
and once we do that
we will have solved the puzzle and put
the numbers in order 1 through 15 by
sliding the discs around
inside the grid
basically thinking inside the box
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can get my books listed on my
website catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker
and you can support me on patreon for
exclusive rewards